я воював
ми поряд гинули люди мої дуже близькі
пішли воювати за Україну тому тут
буде завжди Україна я ніколи не зраджу
пам'яті ремонту тобто дуже мама пішла
би далі сюди сім'ї звичайно ми думали з
нової але ми звідси ви не пішли
ніколи ніколи
немає дають поранених це не кінець свій біг
не освоєно це коли буде україна
повертався на території і коли буде
стояти український прапор сімферополя в
луганську донецьку
кордон України контролюватиме
українські парильники і тоді було не до
кінцевого
знаходитесь лише 3 роки російських
з відблисків тонкі такі проходила ще
моноблок збори ж то можу 2s бар
для чолузь саша
на бік і у світі та 10
я повернувся треба його прожити
максимально прогрес то максимально
через працювати для свого місця для
своєму краї
був такий момент взяли зброї захищати
країну ви зараз як би треба дійство
навести порядок є розумні люди у
яких у голові нормальні ідеї які
можуть просто налагодити механізм щоб
працювала щоб місцевий бюджет шкіл на
покращення життя людей міста
вашому місті дуже багато хороших
патріотично налаштованих людей які
яким як бали за Україну
європейська солідарність це як
платформа для об'єднання людей яким
небайдужа доля нашого міста та
України
[музика]